月曜日はちょっと鬱ですはじめ社長です次今日でこれとなる語の授業が終わりました
強気で来週はポルトガル語のテストで実質北の大学生活の使命となるのはポルトガル
このテストですこれとなること他の授業の単位をしっかり摂っていればひとまず大学は
卒業でございます常に卒業が俺も
ありますよに卒業や俺もやばいよ始めた卒業ね大学もこう大学が終わるなっていう
ちょっと実感が出てきております今日はちょっと真面目なお話をしますから今日は
ちょっと真面目なお話をします
いやーちょっとマクドナルドさんがにはなんか変なのをしててえっとね名前募集
バーガーというハンバーガーを売っているみたいです一部の店舗で寝ているだし
て牧草でちょっと食べたいなと思ってたまたまゲットできたんですよ今日大丈夫
マーシュがすぐ八景図がまっすぐなんですこちらで北海道産ほくほくポテトとチェダー
チーズに焦がし醤油風味の特製オニオンソースクッキーつ中 cb ぐバーガーという
名前が仮についているみたいなんですけどもちなみに明日からですね月2日から
マクドナルドどこのお店でも入るらしいです北海道産北区でどちらチーズに来が4周3
畳
の特製オニオンソースに聞いた寿司バーガーなんですけどもうちょっと長すぎるので
新しい名前を募集しているらしいですねそれが2月2日から名前ボススタントでこの
名前を敷いバーガーの名前を応募してお名前のハンバーガーにこれがなった人は版
だが付い年分ゲットできるみたいです目星ばが10年分相当の商品これが390円で
190かける366日かける10年目で100円ず23,500円をプレゼントロス
です
やるしかでやるしかねーぞお前このハンマーからダメだってたやつね142万円
もらえる
よろしくねだったの
団地で商品するに行きますこれをガーゼで取りに行くからね z やってる
ハンバーガー1年分プレゼントとかもちょっと当たってるんであるんですよある司令
民具選手もあるから俺ならきっと当たるんですよねちょっと詳しいことは知らないん
ですけど名前後セイバーが釣れ使ってみたいにちょっと食べてみましょうてくらいお
おーなんかこんな感じですはポテトが入ってるポイントとお肉が入ってますねちゃーん
チーズバカ言ってるのかデーター8 n 入ってたアーウィンな香りがすごい良いです
ねこれを実際食べて名前をてみなきゃいけないんだびょんずに前の証券を手に入れる
運命的な瞬間をねちょっと見せようと思います同じじゃないで応募があった時は抽選に
なるらしいんであんまりこう言ったらだめじゃん言ったらみんな俺のハンバーガーダメ
でしたらみんなで抽選になるかなってどうすればいいの全数が食べてみてどんなジャン
以下ちょっと感じてみましょう仕上げますん
なるほどなるほどオニオンソースが美味しいな踏まえおいしいポテトもちゃんと
美味しいなぁこれ
美味しいをにアサストポテトはすごいマッチしてます北海嬢さんって感じでさ
こんなそう現在総研が頭に広がってくるんですよ大草原が広がってきていろいろ原っぱ
の真ん中に行きかけんさんがいる感じですこれの生
いいかいやたぶんねまつがいなく普通な名前だとダメなんですよただインパクトに
欠ける名前だと絶対受かんないしてたら同じようなこと考えてる奴らがたくさんいる
からダメなんでほどインパクトのねもう
えっなにこれぐらいのリアクションになるような中でつけないと多分
商品142前は手に入らないと思いますカードどれここでバットこの名前にしますって
言うとみんな真似しちゃうと俺たちで
そのさ抽選になっちゃうから何度かちょっと候補上げとかその中から多分ね名前を
入れるよ
ここ3つくらい考えましたいや普通長いはためしちゃうなんてまでもう難しいなぁ国会
道の感じがすごいかなぁとりあえずひとつ目考えました
ちょっとねちんちんバーガーでそれ時にハンバーガー関係なくてもインパクトを上げを
求めた名前ですね目に留まればいいなぐらいの感じ
行くはちんちんバーガー
だめだたまやべちんちんババアしか思い浮かばないこれじゃただの中国製だえー何だろ
うってと山の動画見よ
ポテトバウザー
あっはい
難しいのでまずね本当に難しいはい
チョコはおかずだから食べれないんだよつく左前打差ポテトバーガーかそういう手も
あるからなあー
ああオニポテを[ __ ]後にポンとチーズバーガー
ちょっと普通かななんでも一候補として挙げておきましょう原人バーガーたオニポテん
チーズバーガー忘れちゃったオニポテチーズだがかちんちん丸なんかもう一つ難や
もっとインパクトなやつ欲しいなぁ
結局でいろんなものが入っているから難しいですよね何だろう
韋駄天春のルキウスでベルギーいうスーパー水 zx 360歩いた店東海道ひざくり
中峠光と闇の間に生まれしフレッシュネスバーガー
これ難しいよ
そうだ
労組お尻ティ雪原に話しっかりた作物のユートピア dark side of
pressure of カレーカレーじゃねーよ dark side of
フレッシュネスバーガーとかでもいいかもしです根付かせんですけど相撲ちょっと考え
て応募してみますからこれねあの他の人も折っちゃうと俺のあたりヶ月減るからみんな
応募しなくていいよちょっとねほんとちゃんとセンサーを考えて分ちょっと100円ず
3番欲しいのでちょっと頑張ってみよう
思います強気で名前募集馬が2月2日火曜日から全国のマクドナルドで売ってるみたい
ですよかったら食べてみてください
普通においしかったですじゃん